STEVE: WELL
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP ATTENDED THE
COMMEMORATION OF THE 100th AN
ANNIVERSARY OF THE END OF THE
WORLD WAR, PRESIDENT MACRON
LAUNCHED A POLITICAL ATTACK.
HERE IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP SAID A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
>> YOU KNOW THEY HAVE A WORD.
IT SORT OF BECAME OLD FASHIONED.
IT'S CALLED A NATIONALIST.
AND I SAY REALLY?
WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO USE THAT
WORD.
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM?
I'M A NATIONALIST.
OKAY.
STEVE: SO WHAT ON EARTH COULD
EMANUEL MACRON HAVE MEANT WHEN
HE SAID THIS TODAY.
>> Translator: PATRIOTISM IS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF NATIONALISM.
NATIONALISM IS A BETRAYAL OF
PATRIOTISM BY SAYING OUR
INTERESTS FIRST, WHO CARES ABOUT
THE OTHERS.
WE ERASE WHAT A NATION HOLDS
DEAREST, WHAT GIVES IT LIFE,
WHAT MAKES IT GREAT AND WHAT SE
SENL.
IS
ESSENTIAL.
STEVE: LET'S TAKE HIS WORDS AT
FACE VALUE.
HE SAID PATRIOTISM IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF NATIONALISM.
IS IT?
I LOOKED IT UP ON GOOGLE.
THE DEFINITION OF NATIONALISM
IS, QUOTE, PATRIOTIC FEELING,
PRINCIPLES OR EFFORTS.
THE FIRST SYNONYM, THAT MEANS
THE SAME MEANING AS, NOT THE
OPPOSITE, LISTED FOR NATIONALISM
IS LITERALLY PATRIOTISM AND
THAT'S ACCORDING TO THE
GLOBALISTS AT GOOGLE.
LET'S TAKE HIS ARGUMENT SUCH AS
IT IS SERIOUSLY.
THE PRESIDENT OF FRANCE IS
SAYING IT'S WRONG TO PUT YOUR
OWN COUNTRY'S INTERESTS FIRST.
HE THINKS SOMETHING ELSE,
PERHAPS THE EUROPEAN INTEREST
OAR THE GLOBAL INTEREST SHOULD
COME FIRST.
BUT WHO DECIDES WHAT THAT IS.
WHERE DOES THE LEGITIMACY COME
FROM.
HOW IS IT ACCOUNTABLE AND TO
WHOM.
WHAT IS MACRON'S MANDATE EXACTLY
FOR PRIVILEGING THE EUROPEAN OR
THE GLOBAL OVER THE NATIONALS.
HE WAS ELECTED WITH FRENCH
VOTES, NOT GLOBAL VOTES.
JUST LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED WITH AMERICAN VOTES.
AT LEAST HE SEEMS TO UNDERSTAND
THAT.
AND UNDERSTAND WHO HE'S
ACCOUNTABLE TO.
MACRON'S ATTACK ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS HIGHLY REVEALING.
IT LAYS BARE THE ASTONISHING
ARROGANCE OF THE GLOBALIST
RULING CLASS WHO THINK IT'S
THEIR MORAL DUTY TO IGNORE
DEMOCRACY AND INSTEAD RUN THE
WORLD ACCORDING TO WHATEVER
MAKES LIFE EASIER FOR THE
RUTHLESS AND HEARTLESS GLOBAL
CORPORATIONS THAT MACRON AND HIS
GANG OF ELITISTS SERVE.
AND THEY HAVE THE NERVE TO
LECTURE PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT
MORALITY.
ONE LAST POINT ON ALL OF THIS.
I WAS READING THIS BOOK, "WHAT
IS THE CONSTITUTION" WITH ONE OF
MY SONS THIS WEEK.
IT TELLS A STORY OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND HERE IS
SOMETHING THAT CAUGHT MY EYE.
SOME LEADERS LIKE GEORGE
WASHINGTON, JAMES MADISON AND
ALEXANDER HAMILTON WANTED THE
UNITED STATES TO BE A STRONG
NATION WITH A SOLID CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT, ONE THAT WOULD
OVERSEE ALL OF THE STATES.
THESE LEADERS WERE CALL
NATIONALISTS.
ALEXANDER HAMILTON WAS A
NATIONALIST.
THAT MIGHT CONVINCE THE ELITE
THAT THERE IS REALLY NOTHING
WRONG WITH PUTTING YOUR COUNTRY